[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen an diesem
ersten freitag im september an meiner
seite des norbert lehmann für den
sponsor familie und das sind die
nachrichten themen von heute
schlange stehen statt traumurlaub der
streik der lufthansa-piloten trifft
130.000 reisende und vielen fehlt das
verständnis
im anderes modus zehn wochen vor den us
zwischenwahlen sucht präsident biden die
konfrontation mit dem tram plage und
für immer nummer zehn zum auftakt der
basketball heim em gibt es eine
besondere ehre für basketball legende
nowitzki und den ersten sieg fürs
deutsche team
ausgerechnet zum ferienende in mehreren
bundesländern ein streik damit machen
sich die pilotinnen und piloten der
lufthansa derzeit wohl keine freunde das
verständnis für ihren arbeitskampf ist
begrenzt versucht wird dass der
flugbetrieb zumindest morgen wieder
schnell in die gänge kommt andrea meuser
berichtet
800 flüge ausgefallen
130.000 passagiere betroffen das sind
die kennzahlen des heutigen streiktages
ein streik vor einem der letzten
ferienwochenende da versuchten viele
noch schnell umzubuchen andere sind
gestrandet wo sie nie hinwollten es gab
reichlich unmut für die piloten habe ich
eigentlich kein verständnis weil für uns
krankenschwestern war ja nur klatschen
und ich bin auch sauer das war mit
steuergeldern die lufthansa
subventionierten absolut absolute
sauerei der versuch der lufthansa
juristisch gegen den streit vorzugehen
war am nachmittag gescheitert und so hob
an den drehkreuzen münchen und frankfurt
kein einziger lufthansa flieger ab
landen durfte nur wer von nicht
deutschen flughäfen aus gestartet war
auch düsseldorf berlin und hamburg
meldeten zahlreiche ausfälle ausgerufen
hatte die gewerkschaft cockpit den
streik in der nacht zum donnerstag
nachdem die tarifverhandlungen mit der
lufthansa gescheitert waren zu diesem
zeitpunkt stand die forderung nach 5,5
prozent mehr gehalt und einem
automatisierten
inflationsausgleich ab 20 23 gegen das
lufthansa angebot einer monatlichen
pauschale von 900 euro laufzeit 1
halbjahr das entspricht 18 prozent in
den unteren gehaltsklassen und fünf
prozent auch in oberen gehaltsklassen im
mittel macht das eine gehaltserhöhung
von zehn prozent aus und das halten wir
schon für ein sehr gutes angebot wobei
geld sozusagen nur der offizielle teil
des konfliktes der konzernumbau mit bald
zwei billig linien und schlechteren
tarifen der unausgesprochene aber
mindestens ebenso wichtige ich bin
zuversichtlich dass das unternehmen
jetzt auf uns zukommen wird mit einem
verbesserten angebot und dass wir am
tariftisch zueinander kommen bis heute
nacht um 12 uhr soll der streik dauern
vereinzelt aber könnte es auch morgen
noch zu ausfällen kommen
angesichts immer weiter steigender
energiepreise will die ampel koalition
so schnell wie möglich entscheiden wie
ein drittes entlastungspaket aussehen
könnte morgen kommt deshalb der
koalitionsausschuss zusammen einigkeit
herrscht darüber dass vor allem
geringverdienende sowie rentnerinnen und
rentner berücksichtigt werden sollen
jack und männer die in berlin was hinter
morgen die größten knackpunkte
die bundesregierung hat ja schon
angekündigt dass sie ein wuchtiges
entlastungs paket entscheiden will und
jetzt müssen die koalitionspartner eben
maßnahmen entscheiden die diesen namen
auch verdienen und nach unseren
informationen soll es mit den beratungen
darüber morgen früh um neun losgehen im
kanzleramt treffen sich dann die spitzen
der koalitionsparteien und der
bundesregierung und beraten vor allem
über zwei fragen nämlich zum einen wer
soll wie und in welcher höhe entlastet
werden bleibt es dabei
entlastungen für diejenigen die bisher
noch nichts bekommen haben nämlich
rentnerinnen und rentner studierende
oder auch sozialhilfeempfänger oder geht
kann man den kreis noch erweitern
darüber hinaus und es wird natürlich um
die frage gehen woher kommt das geld
bleibt es beim geld bei dem einstelligen
milliardenbetrag den christian lindner
als spielraum sieht im aktuellen
bundeshaushalt oder setzen sich der spd
und grüne durch die sagen da muss doch
noch mehr gehen zum beispiel über einen
nachtragshaushalt oder über eine über
gewinn steuert da wird es sehr viel zu
diskutieren geben ist es noch nicht ganz
klar ob die fragen alle an einem
vormittag ausgeräumt werden können
dankeschön für diese informationen aus
berlin gundula penalty
auf hilfe hoffen auch die menschen in
den deutschen braunkohle revieren
möglichst bis 2030 will die regierung
aus der kohle aussteigen 40 milliarden
euro sollen die betroffenen regionen
unterstützen allein 17 milliarden davon
bekommt die lausitz dort in spreetal
traf der bundeskanzler heute die
ministerpräsidenten der ostdeutschen
braunkohle länder man sei auf einem
guten weg heißt es doch bei den menschen
steigt der frust stephan kolck es
sieht aus wie ein tümpel und sollte doch
längst der teich der zukunft sein
inmitten eines attraktiven null energie
wohngebietes in weißwasser die stadt von
morgen bauen das war die idee passiert
ist bisher nichts die lausitz nach der
kohle das sind bislang vor allem
ehrgeizige ideen auf papier bei manchem
sinkt die zuversicht auch daran dass der
bund seinen teil leisten wird wie ist es
denn mit den strukturwandel projekten
des bundes spezielle infrastruktur
speziell die verbindung zwischen berlin
und görlitz weiter unten die
zweigleisige ausbau elektrifizierung
nach unserem kenntnisstand
ist noch relativ wenig passiert der
kanzler hat den kohle
ministerpräsidenten versprochen dass er
eine eisenbahn in die lausitz bauen wird
doch offenbar muss er auch dafür noch
einiges in der eigenen regierung bewegen
dass wir verstehen dass struktur
entwicklung manchmal genau andersrum
geht indem wir eine eisenbahnverbindung
errichten bestimmte infrastrukturen
bauen entsteht das ist der rahmen in dem
eine wirtschaftlichkeit des projekts
überhaupt erst sich ergeben kann eine
solche zuganbindung an berlin würde die
region beleben glauben viele projekte in
forschung und infrastruktur könnten
folgen einer bundesbehörde wurde in
weißwasser ja bereits angesiedelt aber
reicht das wir brauchen hier kinder
verwaltung oder so als ob man wirklich
arbeitsplätze für die normalen
handwerker und die normalen arbeiter das
projekt für die region das to to war es
nicht schwierig den leuten geht es
schlecht vielleicht tut sich jetzt
bisserl was wenn der kanzler kommt
die politiker geben sich überzeugt dass
das projekt strukturwandel auf die
schiene gesetzt ist die lausitzer hoffen
dass das ganze nun auch fahrt aufnimmt
das russische gas unternehmen gazprom
wird anders als angekündigt weiterhin
kein gas über nord stream einst nach
deutschland liefern die leitung sei
komplett abgestellt teilte das
unternehmen soeben mit grund sei ein
technisches problem eigentlich war
angekündigt die lieferungen nach einem 3
tägigen stopp ab morgen wieder
aufzunehmen über nord stream 1 kamen
zuletzt nur noch etwa 20 prozent der
ursprünglichen menge
die erwartungen an die internationalen
atom experten im akw sapori cia in der
ukraine sind groß denn das kraftwerk ist
umkämpft beide seiten schüren die angst
vor einem reaktorunfall doch am zweiten
tag der inspektion wachsen die zweifel
dass die experten in der anlage frei und
ungehindert arbeiten können franziska
von tiesenhausen
so berichtet das russische fernsehen
über den besuch der inspektoren die
sichtweise dort nur dank der gut
koordinierten arbeit der russischen
streitkräfte hätten die experten die
anlage untersuchen können durch die
anlage führte ein experte der russischen
atomenergie agentur
dabei zeigte er den besuchern auch eine
rakete die die ukraine angeblich auf das
kraftwerk abgefeuert haben sollen
dass die experten die anlage neutral
begutachten konnten bezweifelt der
ukrainische kraftwerksbetreiber
energoatom
gegenseitige schuldzuweisungen die
zeigen dass es auch um die
deutungshoheit der lage in sapporo cia
geht
mit den angriffen auf das atomkraftwerk
in sapporo china stellt kiew eine echte
bedrohung für eine nukleare katastrophe
in europa dar das ist nichts als
atomarer terrorismus
beschießen das kraftwerk um die ukraine
unter druck zu setzen europa und die
ganze welt sie wollen dass ihr einknickt
und aufhört die ukraine zu unterstützen
darum betreibt land diese nukleare
erpressung
der großteil der inspektoren ist
mittlerweile wieder abgereist darunter
auch iaea-chef grossi noch in der
ukraine gab er eine erste noch sehr
zurückhaltende auskunft show wir haben
vier wichtige orte ausgewählt die ich
mit eigenen augen ansehen wollte und das
konnte ich auch tun
die arbeit habe aber gerade erst
begonnen so groß wie zwei seiner
mitarbeiter sollen dauerhaft zur
überwachung der lage vor ort bleiben
hannah hebestreit ist etwa eineinhalb
stunden von dem atomkraftwerk entfernt
in der stadt sapporo skiarena wir haben
gehört zwei ihrer mitarbeiter dürfen
länger bleiben ist es ein gutes zeichen
man hat sich der direktor der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde
raphael raus sie durchgesetzt er wollte
ja schon lange eine ständige mission an
dem kraftwerk haben jetzt noch mal
abwarten was dabei herauskommt auf
ukrainischer seite sind die vorbehalte
aber durchaus groß man vertraut einfach
nicht dass die russen keinen einfluss
nehmen auf die inspektoren das haben
sich auch gestern ja schon gesehen wie
es eben in dem weitere rauchen
angedeutet wurde bei der
inspektionsreise von groß sie zu dem
kraftwerk hatten die gastgeber ein solch
umfangreiches besuchsprogramm für ihn
organisiert dass er kaum noch zeit hatte
zu einer vernünftigen kontrolle jetzt
ist groß sie auf dem weg nach wien wo er
in den nächsten minuten eine
pressekonferenz abhalten wird und
dadurch das sehr interessant sein was er
zu den vorwürfen aus der ukraine sagt
eine gute nachricht gibt es noch von dem
reaktor selber einer von den
reaktorblöcken war gestern nach den
gefechten
abgeschaltet worden um vom netz genommen
worden jetzt ist er wieder am netz und
versorgt die ukraine auch wieder mit
strom dankeschön hannah live aus st
fabrizio
wählt wählt wählt ein kämpferischer
appell des us-präsidenten beiden ruf zur
stimmabgabe bei den zwischenwahlen im
november auf es gelte die demokratie zu
retten die sie beiden von seinem
vorgänger trump und dessen anhängern
bedroht aus washington m at wissen
dass die beleuchtung auf rot schaltete
war sicher kein zufall joe biden will
das land warnen die amerikanische
demokratie sei in gefahr
dort shampoo die make america grady gen
republikaner stehen für einen
extremismus der die grundfeste unserer
republik bedroht
der präsident hat philadelphia gewählt
den ort an dem einst
unabhängigkeitserklärung und verfassung
unterzeichnet wurden grundprinzipien
amerika so beiden stunden jetzt auf dem
spiel
sie wollen ein amerika in dem es kein
recht auf abtreibung gibt kein recht auf
privatsphäre auf empfängnisverhütung
kein recht zu heiraten den man liebt sie
unterstützen autoritärer anführer und
schüren das feuer politischer gewalt
beiden erklärt amerika den krieg titelte
foxnews obwohl der präsident
ausdrücklich nur die tram pisten in der
republikanischen partei angesprochen hat
biden hat einen angriff auf die
demokratie gestartet seine politik hat
die seele amerikas verwundet amerikas
geist geschadet und amerikas vertrauen
verraten
derweil verbreitet ex-präsident trump
auf den social media
verschwörungstheorien außerdem sollte
man ihn sofort zum wahlgewinner erklären
oder neuwahlen durchführen joe biden
antwort
ich werde nicht zu sehen wie wahlen von
leuten gestohlen werden die einfach
nicht zugeben wollen dass sie verloren
haben
es wird ein harter emotionaler wahlkampf
für die kongresswahlen im november
und jetzt ein blick nach china das
regelt wegen corona immer wieder
millionenstädte ab wie gerade john dew
die metropole im südwesten lockdown für
sage und schreibe 21 millionen menschen
bei gerade mal 1 157 gemeldeten
neuinfektionen
die einwohner werden jetzt durch
getestet und müssen bis sonntag zu hause
bleiben so sieht die strikte null corona
politik pekings aus seit beginn der
pandemie über den lockdown john dew
miriam stein
werbung für ein angebliches shopping
festival darüber machen sich chinesische
internet nutzerinnen und nutzer gerade
lustig denn so soll das festival aus
hamsterkäufe in chengdu im südwesten
chinas ausgelöst unter anderem durch
eine nachricht in einer chat gruppe es
könnte zu einem lockdown kommen schreibt
ein mann er muss 15 tage in haft und
bekommt eine geldstrafe weil er unruhe
provoziert habe er lag richtig heute
sieht schon du so aus das wort lockdown
nutzen die behörden nicht es heißt
ruhemodus verhängt wegen
157 corona fällen in der 21 millionen
statt die leute sollen zu hause bleiben
aber es ist nicht ganz so streng mit
negativen corona test darf pro haushalt
und tag einer raus zum einkaufen
damit sollen wohl solche bilder wie beim
block dawn in shanghai vermieden werden
wo es in manchen vierteln nicht genug
lebensmittel gab
während der rest der welt versucht mit
dem corona virus zu leben wie in china
jeden einzelnen ausbruch im keim
ersticken zu beginn der pandemie war das
erfolgreich inzwischen haben viele die
extremen maßnahmen satt die auch der
wirtschaft massiv schaden die dynamische
it strategie ist etwas für das sich hier
den ping persönlich verbirgt hat er
dafür persönlich verantwortung
übernommen wenn er davon abrücken würde
käme das einer persönlichen niederlage
gleich deshalb hält der chinesische
präsident hu daran fest und will sich
beim parteitag im oktober eine dritte
amtszeit sichern
in münster starb heute morgen ein
25-jähriger weil er zivilcourage gezeigt
hatte vor einer woche am rande des
christopher street days war der
transsexuelle mann niedergeschlagen
worden nachdem er frauen zur hilfe eilte
die lesben feindlich beleidigt worden
waren vor einer stunde meldete die
polizei sie habe einen 20-jährigen
verdächtigen am hauptbahnhof in münster
festgenommen thomas münten hat mehr von
der festnahme eines tatverdächtigen
wissen die demonstranten in der
münsteraner innenstadt noch nichts als
sie vor wenigen minuten hier
zusammenkommen um dem opfer zu gedenken
traurig trotzig und kämpferisch
[Musik]
am vergangenen samstag hatte sich die
tragödie im münsteraner christopher
street day zugetragen mitten in den mehr
als 10.000 teilnehmern pöbelt ein
unbekannter zwei junge frauen an der
25-jährige will einschreiten den mann
zur rede stellen nach
augenzeugenberichten schlägt der täter
sofort zu das opfer stürzte auf den
hinterkopf und fällt ins koma
das 25-jährige opfer ist nach dem
brutalen angriff am rande des csd am
vergangenen samstag heute morgen
verstorben an der stelle des brutalen
überfalls brennen seit samstag immer
kerzen münster trauert um einen mutigen
bürger
und das leider was wir was wir mit uns
herumtragen was aber hoffentlich nicht
dazu führt dass wir weniger
selbstbewusst durch die gegend laufen
über den 20 jährigen tatverdächtigen und
seinen komplizen ist noch nichts bekannt
in hamburg ist eine der höchstdotierten
wissenschaftszeitung 'nen in europa
verliehen worden der körper preis er
geht in diesem jahr an dem zellbiologen
anthony hyman der 60 jährige brite
forscht in dresden am zelt tröpfchen
seine erkenntnisse bedeuten neue
hoffnung für patienten mit nerven
erkrankungen wie alzheimer oder a ls
denn sie bieten weitere ansätze für
therapien und medikamente
großes hocharbeiten deutschen
basketballer norbert heim em ging gut
los einen traumstart und mehr gala
vorstellung gestern abend 76 zu 63 gegen
frankreich immerhin den olympia-zweiten
von tokio das team mitreißen geradezu
euphorisiert ausspielt und das unter den
augen der deutschen basketball legende
gepusht vom großen dirk nowitzki gelang
ein fantastischer start in die heim em
die deutschen basketballer überzeugten
defensiv und glänzten mit herrlichen
angriffen das ein toller sieg für uns
wir haben alle beigetragen hatten alle
spaß und ich glaube die fans haben das
heute auch genossen die konten erstmal
nowitzkis ehrungen für seine
außergewöhnlichen leistungen im
nationaltrikot genießen ihr wisst ich
immer gerne für mein land gespielt habe
immer alles gegeben und von daher
dann begeisterten seine nachfolger mit
spektakulären körben wie diesem dreier
von rückkehrer daniel theis zur halbzeit
lag deutschland mit 38 zu 31 in führung
der auftritt gegen frankreich in der
zweiten hälfte noch selbstbewusster
modolo auf dennis schröder der kapitän
führte deutschland zu an den
überzeugenden 76 zu 63 erfolg schon
morgen geht es weiter mit der partie
gegen bosnien herzegowina
und dazu mir morgen haben bei uns im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr mit
einem so was von passenden gast dirk
nowitzki
morgen das wm quali spiel der deutschen
fußball frauen gegen die türkei das team
von martina voss tecklenburg beim
abschlusstraining in bursa hochmotiviert
ein sieg im vorletzten gruppenspiel
ja und die wm qualifikation wäre
geschafft die partie zu sehen bei uns im
zdf morgen ab 14 uhr 30 und
geschafft hat es juli niemeyer in die
dritte runde der us open die letzte
deutsche tennis spielerin im turnier
siegte nach einem durchaus holprigen
start 0 zu 3 lag die 23-jährige gegen
julia putin server zurück doch dieser
breakball zum 2 3 im ersten satz zeigt
ihre mentale stärke im juli machte der
kasachen zu schaffen dann habe ich so
langsam ins match gefunden habe mich
dann auch angefangen wohlzufühlen habe
angefangen die ballwechsel zu dominieren
was gegen sie extrem wichtig ist
niemeyer ließ sich nicht mehr aus der
ruhe bringen gewann satz eins mit einem
arzt zum 6 4 im zweiten satz war die
deutsche die in littleton bereits im
viertelfinale stand dann die
dominierende spielerin sie gewann 6 3
und trifft am samstag auf die chinesin
das was von sport dankeschön das wetter
bringt im südwesten teils kräftige
schauer und gewitter der nordosten
bleibt trocken details hat gleich
christa orden im heute journal um 10
begrüßte christian sievers wir danken
für ihr interesse und wünschen ein
schönes wochen hinter es morgen wenn sie
mal auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das satellitenbild von heute
zeigt uns einige quellwolken hier über
deutschland über frankreich da liegen
aber schon die kompakteren wolken die
uns jetzt schauer und gewitter bringen
und zwar heute nacht aus dem südwesten
kommt das ganze bis morgen früh voran zu
einer linie eifel alpenvorland morgen
über tag breiten sich schauer und
gewitter dann weiter aus und können auch
nordrhein westfalen bis nach bayern am
abend auch das erzgebirge erreichen die
gewitter können örtlich auch mal
kräftigen starkregen bringen
größtenteils können wir uns aber einfach
über regen freuen doch das geht nicht
für den nordosten des landes schon heute
nacht in der es auf 16 bis teils nur
sechs grad abkühlt erstes hier trocken
und oft klar und auch morgen haben wir
im nordosten einen trockenen sonne
wolken mix denn dieser frische östliche
wind der held mit seiner trockenen
continental luft gegen diese feuchte
instabile luft aus dem südwesten
am meisten sonne haben wir wohl richtung
niedersachsen deswegen auch von hier bis
zum niederrhein sommerliche 25 bis 27
grad morgen sonst 20 bis 24 grad in den
nächsten tagen geht es auch sommerlich
am montag im westen sogar hochsommerlich
weiter dazu gibt es ruhiges wetter nur
einzelne schauer und gewitter das ändert
sich dann am dienstag 1